welcome back everyone
this is lecture 20 of cs229
and the main topic for today will be
variational auto encoders so variational
auto encoders
is probably one of the
simplest deep generative models uh so
deep generative models
is a very hot topic in machine learning
right now
where we try to build generative models
of our data using neural networks
and variational auto encoders was one of
the uh
one of the early early models which
made good progress in this field and is
also probably the model that
you know one should uh start studying
first because it has
the key components that are kind of
necessary that are used in in more
fancier models
so uh for all for for studying
variational auto encoders
first we will look at you know simple
auto encoders uh
auto encoders have a long history and um
we will look at you know what simple
auto encoders are
and then we'll kind of switch gears back
into
expectation maximization and look at a
very
look at a few variants of expectation
maximization because that that ah kind
of
gives good motivation into variational
autoencoders we will
first study something called as mcmc
expectation maximizer mcm cem where mcmc
stands for
markov chain monte carlo and we will
also
we will also have a quick look at
variational inference which is
kind of like a counterpart to monte
carlo techniques
and then we will look at yet another
variant of em called variation em
and then switch gears into the
variational auto encoder itself so
that's the
plan for today and uh so if if
if in terms of the overall course if you
are able to cover this today then
probably today will be kind of
uh the last uh math intensive class
we'll have one more class on
on friday we'll where we'll be covering
more
um general topics like um
like um um evaluation metrics and and
you know general tips for
uh executing machine learning projects
that will not be as
math heavy so probably this is going to
be the last math heavy class and next
week we'll be just doing review of
all the uh topics that we have done in
the course
and also the review that we do next week
will
you know kind of uh will be suggestive
of the kind of topics that are important
for your final exam
so we'll be stressing more on topics
that are um important for the final exam
um so that you can focus on them yes
questions
so the final is cumulative uh it is it
is
uh since we did not have a midterm it's
you know it's cumulative it covers
everything yeah
uh so a quick recap of what we covered
in the last class so in the last class
we mostly dealt with the principle
called the maximum entropy principle
where entropy of a probability
distribution is defined as
the exp the expectation of the negative
log of
the probability value itself and the
maximum entropy principle
suggests that we should maximize the
entropy
of a probability distribution that we
are trying to estimate subject to
some constraints where most of the times
the constraints
are expectation of some function of
the of the variable or of the space over
which the distribution is defined
and we want the expectations to be equal
to the empirical of the
you know empirical expectations
and these generally come from data right
this where data comes in into the
maximum entropy principle because they
serve as the
as the values to which we want the
constraints to satisfy right so
subject to subject to these constraints
we get an entire
family or an entire class of probability
distributions
that satisfy this constraint right so
supposing these uh
you know t 1 and t 2 are like you know
x and x square so if t 1 of x
equals x t 2 of x equals x square
then basically the constraints that we
are trying to express is the first
moment of the data should be you know
some
the first moment of the of the of the
data the second moment of the
distribution should be the second moment
of the data and so on
and subject to these constraints we
basically have an infinite number of
probability distributions in general
because satisfying just two or three
constraints is is uh
is pretty easy and then the maximum
enterprise principle suggests that
among the class of all these candidate
probability distributions that satisfy
these
moments the one that we want to choose
is the one that maximizes
entropy yes question
so moments are you know so expectation
of
x is called the first moment expectation
of x square is the second moment
expectation of x cube is the third
moment and so on
right so uh the
the the the the objective that we want
to maximize is the
entropy i think there was also a
question somebody asked
where why are we trying to maximize
entropy and why not maximize variance
maximizing variance for example will so
supposing our
probability distribution is defined on
the range a to b
right finite support now ah if we want
a distribution that has high sensor
uncertainty
across then we need the probability
uh pdf to look like this which which
uniformly assigns 1 over b minus a
density to all the
all the areas now if you want to just
maximize variance
instead of maximizing entropy then the
distribution that we have
will be something like this a and b
where half the masses here have the
masses here
right so this maximizes variance
but it does not necessarily mean that
you are maximizing uncertainty
right so maximizing variance does not
necess is not something that we want to
do if we want to just increase our
uncertainty and and and
um kind of stay unbiased about our
estimate of
of what the probability distribution is
right so
uh maximum entropy principles tells us
that
satisfy these constraints and among the
all the distribution that satisfies
choose the one that
has the highest entropy and we saw that
this
is equal to this kind of dual problem
where the dual problem is maximum
likelihood where
we want to if we were to start from
another direction where we want to
perform
maximum likelihood and the
the the probability distribution if we
assume
is part of the exponential family where
the sufficient statistics of the
exponential family
are basically the constraints that we
want to satisfy then these two problems
are equivalent
in other words maximum entropy
naturally gives rise to the exponential
family
exponential family of probability
distributions right and then we kind of
saw this this somewhat related topic
called calibration which is
you know super important if you're
building uh you know real world
predictive models real world forecasting
models so calibration
is this property where the predicted
probabilities you know match the
observed frequencies
where when you when you when you say
that some some outcome has a probability
of
you know say 80 percent let us say it is
going to rain tomorrow
with probability 80 percent then if you
collect the set of all predictions where
the prediction was 80 percent
then approximately 0.8 fraction of those
uh true outcomes it actually should have
rained right not more not less it should
have
the the uh fraction of observed outcomes
should match the predicted probability
that that then
then that model is then said to be well
calibrated against
against that distribution and we also
saw that
calibration and accuracy are kind of
orthogonal
one does not necessarily imply the other
you can have you know well calibrated
models that are
you know that have very poor accuracy
and vice versa
and related to this
concept of calibration there is this
concept called a proper scoring rule so
you can think of loss functions
as being a proper scoring rule if they
take
a forecast distribution and some actual
outcome
that was observed and kind of ah
basically give a score to the forecaster
based on what the actual outcome was
right and you can think of it as a loss
function where you know the smaller the
score
the better the forecaster was right and
a proper scoring rule is one that
satisfies this property
where given any two probability
distributions p and q
you know where if we assume q is like
the real world occurrence
uh or the real world uh probability
distribution of the true probability
distributions
and if x's are being sampled from this
you know real world and these
real world samples are used to to score
the
score the forecasters probability
distribution
where you know these are the predictions
then only when the
only when the prediction is the true
probability
the loss will be the lowest for any
other probability distribution being
uh predicted if the true events are
sampled from q
then the expected expected score
for the other forecast will always be
higher than
the expected score for the true function
being a true distribution
being forecasted right so this is called
a prop a proper scoring rule and if
we build models that optimize for proper
scoring rules
that is if if our loss function is
penalizing our prediction p
using some proper scoring rule
you know and and subject to few other
you know constraints
it's easy to see that uh that that
uh proper scoring rules encourages our
model
to predict probabilities that are
forecasted because
we are minimized at at uh we are
minimized when the predicted probability
equal to the real world uh occurrence of
data
right and we saw the connection to
maximum entropy
of this proper scoring rule that if we
satisfy if we
strive to maximize the entropy or use
the maximum entropy principle
then as a consequence the last function
that we get
is going to be the negative log p of x
and that's that's that comes directly
from this and we are trying to maximize
this
instead we can minimize negative log
p of x right so the negative log
likelihood is just the loss function of
the maximum likelihood objective
and we saw that if you know f of p
x equals negative log p of x is a proper
scoring rule
because you know if we just plug minus
log p of x here
and ah take it to the other side or you
know bring that
to the other side we get that k l
divergence is always greater than equal
to zero which is
um you know which is true that we've
also seen that in the homework
so essentially the the uh the big
picture is that
maximum entropy principle encourage us
to
make calibrated predictions right that's
that's the big story from
from last class any questions on this
before we move on to today's topics
okay cool so today uh we'll switch gears
and talk about
variational auto encoders and the first
the first step in this journey will be
to have a look at what auto encoders are
in general
so to study auto encoders we again go
back to neural networks
right so in neural networks
so that the only kind of neural networks
that you studied so far are those that
can be used in a supervised setting
where we have some we start with some
input layer
we started with some input layer and
then we had all these hidden layers
right fully connected
at fully connected layers
and we ended up with a single scalar y
hat and we compared it against
you know the ground truth y or the true
label y and out of these two
we constructed a loss
right and this was a scalar and then we
ah minimize the loss that
gave us a scalar valued function as a
function of all the parameters
and then we basically ah you know
optimize the loss by performing gradient
descent
on our loss function and in order to
calculate gradient descent with respect
to all the parameters we will we use the
multivariate calculus chain rule which
was essentially the same as back
propagation
right that's that's uh that's what we
did in supervised learning setting
instead ah now what we are going to do
is
we are only given xs so our training set
is now just a set of xs
x1 through n there is no y
and the goal with auto encoders
the goal with auto encoders is to
learn a way in which we
introduce something called as a
bottleneck and
reconstruct the original data what i
mean by that is we start with
the original with the input layer being
x
right and this used to be d dimensional
right and
this will still be d dimensional right
so this is the input layer
and then we
we have a few fully connected layers
right and we bring it down to some
k dimensional hidden layer
let us call it z right and from this k
dimensional ah hidden layer
we start where where typically k is
smaller than d
from here we start increasing
the dimensions of the hidden layers
until we are back to d dimensional
um d dimensional layer and
this layer will call it x hat and our
loss will now
be to
to minimize x hat minus x
right so we want the output of our
network to be the input itself
this may sound trivial you know because
you know all what the network has to do
is to you know take the input and
give the same thing as the output but
the the
challenge for the network is that it has
to basically
take this data transformation through
this bottleneck layer z
which has dimension k which is much
smaller than d
right what this what this ah encourages
the model to do
is to learn some kind of a low
dimensional representation
of our high dimensional input data
and then starting with this low
dimensional representation
we we map it back into the high
dimensional
high dimensional data itself right and
if the model is able to
successfully minimize this loss you know
to a satisfactory level
then essentially the model has learned
to compress data into
some kind of some kind of a latent state
or
a hidden state right so here
we typically call the parameters of the
first half of the network
let us call these parameters as fee so
these are all the weights and biases of
all the layers
until you know the hidden layer that we
are interested in
and let us call the weights and biases
of all the
layers starting from this hidden layer z
all the way until x hat which is the
reconstruction
to be lets call it theta
right and so the loss is now essentially
you know sum over i equals one to n
where small n is the number of examples
we want to minimize the norm between x
i minus
let us give them names so this part of
the network
which takes as input x and outputs z
let's call it the encoder
right so it encodes data into some
hidden representation z
and we'll call the second half of the
network that takes z
as the input and outputs x hat as the
output
we'll call that the decoder
right and the encoder is parameterized
by
fee and the decoder is parameterized by
theta
right so now the loss is
ah x minus x hat minus
so first we want to encode
x i and the parameter here is phi
and we want to take this you know this
is essentially equal
we can call this z i right and then we
want to
take the z i and and feed it as input to
the decoder
right so we feed this into the decoder
and this decoder is parameterized by
theta right
and this this ah the version that comes
out of the decoder that is the the
original x encoded through the encoder
and decode that encoding
back from the decoder now this whole
thing is x hat i
so we want to minimize the norm between
x i
and x hat i where the loss
is a function of theta and phi
right so this objective is basically
the gives you what is called as the auto
encoder
we call it an auto encoder because we
want to encode something and decode it
back to the same thing
right which which is where the the word
auto comes in and
the way we we go about uh training this
is through
back propagation right this is going to
be a scalar loss because it is the norm
of a vector or the norm squared of a
vector so we are starting with
you know some kind of a scalar loss
so ah you can you can think of this as
you know
you you come to an encoded state and
decode it back
into x hat
and
decode it back into x hat
and we have provided a second copy of x
itself
so this is d dimensional this
is d dimensional so start from the input
encode it decode it you get x hat take
the
take the original another copy of x and
using these two
construct the last to be x minus
x hat square and this is a scalar loss
this will be in r right and this gives
us a loss function
against which we can now perform back
propagation and train all the
model parameters phi and theta these are
basically the weights and biases
in the first half and the second half of
the network
and the way you go about doing back
propagation is exactly how
we saw in the in the neural network
lectures yes question
good question so the the question is you
know how is this different from pca
right in pca we are doing something very
similar we start with a
d dimensional data and project it uh
down into
a low a k dimensional uh hidden
representation
and then uh in in pca we the the
objective there was the
to minimize the the distance between
uh between every point and its
projection right
the the main difference between pca and
an auto encoder is that in pca
the transformation from x to z is
strictly linear
right here you can have multiple hidden
layers
which have multiple non-linearities
so yes so so technically you
you could perform a pca with this thing
um except in pca you might also
require this would you need the x hat
mapping
should this be the inverse you can you
can do something very similar to pca
with this without nonlinearities yeah
you can do it
so this is not the same as pca because
here you know things can be non-linear
the the reason why you would want to do
the uh to do this with data in real life
is because you want to you want to learn
some kind of uh
a useful hidden representation that has
some kind of a latent meaning
right um and uh we will see with
variational auto encoders of how
this ah z representation is kind of ah
you know
where where the the uh hidden
representation with variational auto
encoders
will will ah end up having some kind of
a meaning we
we'll see later today right so this is
this is
a variational auto encoders and think of
this you can i know in a simplistic term
think of this as dimensionality
reduction or
ah you know a way in which you are just
learning
some kind of a compact representation
for your data
there are variations of auto encoders
called denoising auto encoders
where in denoising auto encoders you
you learn how to denoise your data by
training
by feeding some kind of a noisy version
of the input and in the loss
so so in the you feed a noisy version of
the input
but try to recover the original x right
and that gives you something called as
the denoising auto encoder where the the
uh where the network learns to denoise
the training data and
you know hopefully generalizes to
denoising unseen data as well right so
that's that's
uh there are many variants to uh the
auto encoder
okay any questions on this and this is
all we're going to talk about auto
encoders and we're going to
switch to a different topic yes
so there are no labels here so the the
the task
here is to not predict a label but the
task here
is to go through this bottleneck and
reconstruct the original data itself
that's the task
so the question is if if we consider z
to be the output of the first
um first half of the network
what should the output and the answer is
whatever the network realizes is the
optimum z
that helps it recover back x hat right
it
is the the we are not we we are not
providing any kind of supervision of
what
z should be all we are saying is
whatever z
comes out of the first half should be
the z
that you feed into the second half that
that performs good reconstruction of x
yes another question
are just two different parameters
they're not necessarily like inverses
no we we don't assume p and theta to be
goal going to inverses like somehow to
detach the second half of it and use
that as a
compression yeah so so the the eventual
goal is
uh uh to to use only the first half on
unseen data to get their
you know hidden representations or the
compact representation so you can you
can
you know chop your network at this point
and use it as an encoder where you're
getting some kind of a compressed
uh compressed representation
yeah so so the question is you know
what's the dimension of z what's the you
know uh
how many layers do we have those are all
those are all hyper parameters that you
wanna that you wanna tune
where you can you can train with you
know your training data and see how well
the reconstruction is happening on a
test data and you know you can kind of
do your bias variance analysis there
next question
analysis with no conditions
right so uh relation to factor analysis
let's take that offline uh that's that's
kind of
uh tangential to our our topic right now
but you know i'm happy to answer that
uh after the lecture right so um
the this is this is uh the auto encoder
and we'll come back to auto encoder in
in a few minutes in the in the mean time
uh a few more related topics for for our
build up
so next ah so this was auto encoders
2 m c
m c e m right
so um a quick recall of e m
so in em we
we perform this iterative procedure of
going through two steps the e step and
the m step over and over again until we
converge
where the e step
was for all
i where i is indexing your data elements
set q i
of z will be equal to p
of z given
x i under the current parameter theta
and then ah to make this more clear let
us also give
time indexes so at the teeth iteration
we use
theta t
right and in the m step
we perform theta t
plus 1 to be equal to
i'm just going to write it for one
example ah
but you know it's basically just the sum
over
all examples arg
max theta of
the elbow i am going to write out the
elbow in in full form
sum over z q
t of z
times log p
of x z
parameterized by theta over
q i t of
z all right ah
this in fact i am just writing it in
terms of one example
all right let let me just write in terms
of all the examples
so i equals one to n you have
x i z i right
and c i here
and um in this we can make a
a few comments first of all we assume
that we we could
perform this posterior calculation p of
z given x we could calculate this
ah somehow right this is kind of an
implicit assumption in e m
that we can calculate this posterior
distribution p of z even x
right that may or may not hold true in
practice
right so that was that was kind of
a big assumption that we kind of quietly
swept it under the rug and assumed we
could
you know calculate the posterior
distribution somehow now the challenge
comes when you're considering you know
complex models
for example suppose suppose our model is
something like this right
so z comes from some normal distribution
with mean 0
and i k times k right
a continuous latent variable z and let
us say
x given z is
some kind of a thats a neural network
right
neural network with parameter theta
that takes in as input z
right so z is see z is is sampled from
some
gaussian distribution and we feed that
gaussian distribution
so imagine the second half of this
network right
we feed that z into a neural network
and out will come our data the data that
we observe
right in this kind of a setting where
our model
is is so complex that calculating
p of z given x is pretty much
you know impossible there's no way we
can you know take
take some arbitrary neural network and
calculate the posterior of z given x
in in a closed form estimate right it
need not be a neural network it could be
any kind of you know some complex model
some complex
z i is parameterized by theta right this
could be hierarchical it could be you
know any any kind of a complex model
now the question is how do we perform em
in the setting to estimate our
parameters theta
right because we are no longer able to
come up with a closed form estimate for
p of z given ah z given x right
and this is where um
we can make a few observations so first
of all in
e m in the m step
we are holding q fixed right we saw this
previously as well the only place where
the variable that we are optimizing this
theta the only place it shows up is over
here
right while you are performing this is
arc max this is the only theta that we
are adjusting to perform the arg max
right
everything else here are constants right
and so we can write this as
i think we mentioned uh this earlier as
well that we can all in e m
the m step can always be written as
one to n sum over z
q i t of
v i log
p of x i
z i rise by theta
right these two are always the same
will always are equivalent because
log of a by b can be written as log a
minus log b
and log b is essentially a constant with
respect to theta
so we can just get rid of the
denominator inside the log
right and now you know if you look at
this
in this form we kind of get another
insight
the insight is that even though
we wanted to you even though in the e
step we say we want to calculate
q the probability distribution of
of the posterior of z
we don't really want to calculate the
density values itself right
the only way q gets used in the m step
is to ca is to ah is to construct this
expectation
right so this is i equals one to n
expectation of z i coming from
q i of t of
log p x i z i
theta okay
r max
so even though q i appears
in this in this expression it is only
used
to take an exp expectation of this
function
right we do not really need to calculate
the density by itself we are only
interested in the density
of of uh density values of q only to
perform this expectation right and using
this insight that the purpose
of q is only to take the expectation
we can instead what we can do is to
approximate this
arc max theta sum over
i equals 1 to n and over here
what we are going to do is to replace
the expectation with the monte carlo
estimate of the expectation
and what that means is instead of
integrating over this function using the
density of q
instead we will take many many samples
of z from q
right and average take the average of
this
across all those samples of z right so
that would look
something like this um let's assume we
take capital t
number of samples for each example and
this would be ah one over capital t
t is probably a bad choice so let's call
it capital m
you know so we're going to use capital m
number of samples for each monte carlo
expectation estimate
ah small m equals 1
through capital m log
p of x i
and z in place of z i i am going to
write
z m where z m
is
z m
of i is sampled from q
i of t right
so we rewrite this expectation as a
monte carlo estimate
where the z's are sampled from cues the
cues however
is still this posterior but there are
many techniques
to sample from a posterior of a complex
probability distribution
even though we don't know how to
evaluate it there are techniques
ah such as you know gibbs sampling
or ah metropolis hastings
so so ah mcmc is a vast vast vast field
where there are many techniques for
sampling from posteriors even though we
don't know how to exactly calculate the
density
of a given point in the posterior but we
can still get samples
right and basically the law of large
numbers tells us
that as m goes to infinity this monte
carlo estimate
will tend to will converge towards the
true expectation
right and so with this technique
you know this is this is a variant of em
where you know even though we do
we we don't know how to calculate uh uh
the posterior distribution
we can approximate the posterior using
monte carlo techniques or sampling
techniques
right so this is this is one way to to
work around
ah complex or hard to compute posteriors
any questions on this this question
the last step yeah so in the last step
what we are doing is
we are replacing this expectation
with the monte carlo estimate of the
expectation
right so we replace this expectation
with the monte carlo estimate of the
expectation
where did the q go q is is is a
distribution from which the zi's are
sampled
right so over here z i was sampled from
q and this was an analytical
expression for the expectation instead
we replace it with the monte carlo
estimate of this expectation
where zi's are sampled from q and we
sample capital
m number of such samples from a qi
and construct this average of this
function
for using those samples as the monte
carlo estimate of the expectations
yes if as you take m to infinity then
these two will evaluate to the same
value
right and that's the law of large
numbers right
so the original em
we constructed a convergence proof where
with every e and m step the likelihood
was only increasing
right we we we saw that proof with
you know likelihood construct the lower
bound and then construct a lower bound
in another lower bound and
at every step we were guaranteed that
you know
the the the theta t's were increasing
the likelihood
but over here that guarantee does not
hold anymore
right because this is an approximation
and not
an approximation of the uh lower bound
and not and not the exact core bond
this question
so with gibb sampling you can sample the
posterior
samples from the posterior
so you we get samples of zs right
and using the sample values of these we
can take the average of the
of the joint good question
right so this is this is one approach to
ah
to addressing interactable posteriors
through this technique called sampling
right and there is you there is this
other kind of
counterpart approach for
approximating complex posteriors which
is called variational inference
right so to ah
when you want to calculate posterior
distributions you basically have three
choices
choice number one is the exact posterior
like you know use math algebra use bayes
rule and and calculate the exact
posterior
if that is not possible you are left
with two other choices choice number two
is to approximate it using gibbs
sampling or or
through some kind of a sampling approach
a monte carlo approach
where you take samples and take the
expectation of the thing you want to you
want to uh
take the expectation off with respect to
the posterior
option number three is variational
inference so variational inference is
another technique to to work around
these
intractable posteriors and in order to
kind of
understand variational inference we
go back to
we go back to the expression we derived
in em which was basically
log p of x was
greater than or equal to elbow
of x with some q
right we derived this using jensen's
inequality
and we left it at this form saying lo
you know
the elbow is a lower bound of the uh
of the log probability of the evidence
right it's the
lower bound of the evidence but how much
is it lower by
right so the question is log p of
x is equal to
alpha of x plus
what right
and in fact the the answer is pretty
straight forward
all what you want to do is take this to
the other side and you get
this is equal to log p of x
minus elbow
right when the elbow is basically this
form
and you plug in this form over here am
not going to do the do the algebra its
pretty straight forward very simple
algebra what you get over here is
basically
the kl divergence between q and
p of z given x
right and this should not be surprising
because when q
is equal to p of z given x we saw that
the elbow is tight and will be exactly
equal to
log p of x right
so it could have been the kl divergence
from p to q
or q to p you know one of those two are
the natural choices
but if you work out the algebra it turns
out that it is you know the kl
divergence from q to p
p of c given x right so
our our ah goal is to
estimate log p of z even x right
and here we are making this observation
that
you know um the kl divergence between q
and ps of
z given x is equal to you know uh this
value over here
so this is basically kind of uh uh
the motivation for how we derive the
variational inference
ah so for variational inference what we
see is
uh lot p of x does not have any q term
in it
right so this is effectively a constant
slot p of x
is basically a constant it has
it has no no q term in it and then we
and then we have the elbow
of x q plus
d k l of q to p of
z given x right so this is a constant
with respect to q with respect to
q and this has a q term and this has a q
term
and we want our q to be
exactly equal to p of z given x
right and or um
that that is that's our eventual goal or
the the ideal goal that z is equal to p
of z given x
but instead with a variational inference
what we what we do
is we
in order to make it as close to p of z
given x as possible
we maximize this with respect to q
now if we maximize this with respect to
q
make this observation that this is
greater than or equal to 0
so for no value of q will this become
negative
right no matter what q we choose will
that become negative if we choose the
best possible q
then this just this term just becomes 0.
so instead of calculating p of z given x
somehow we take this variational
approach
where we say q of z given
or q of or rather p
of z given x
next be approximated by
the arc max
of q in some family
q of
the elbow of x comma q
right if we maximize the elbow
as much as possible with respect to q
we are bounded by log p of x anyways
right so this provides like a ceiling
and if we maximize the elbow as much as
possible
because this is non-negative the
highest possible we can take this when
we maximize this completely
with respect to q we would have
naturally
obtained a q that minimized the kl
divergence between
q and p p of z equal next does that make
sense
right so performing arg max of this
elbow
over q will give us a q
that is very close to p of z given x
and this kind of an approach
where we maximize this lower bound with
respect to q
and obtain a distribution which we
approximated to be p of z
z unix is called variational inference
right and this is you know ah
a kind of a complementary approach
to the sampling based approaches because
in sampling
based approaches you could take an
infinite number
of exam of of samples and eventually
you would get the you would recover the
exact uh
evidence lower bound you would recover
the exact elbow as you took m to
infinity
right whereas over here
most of the times we will not trick out
the exact
posterior but we will end up having some
kind of an approximation
of p of z given x depending on how
flexible
this family of q is
right and over here the technique we
used for sampling
whereas with variational inference that
the technique we use is optimization
right in sampling we do you know
sampling in monte carlo techniques we do
sampling
with variational inference we do
optimization here in the limit
we recover the exact solution whereas
over here
we always get an approximate solution
depending on you know how flexible the
the family queue is
over here if you're familiar with monte
carlo techniques
you never know how good your estimate is
you know you need to keep taking
more and more samples all you know is
eventually
you will reach the exact solution but at
any given time say
you've taken you know 100 samples they
have taken 10 million samples
that you don't know how good or how
close you are to the true